this is our hybrid illusion shirt from
up close
it says close but from far away
it says far it's a hybrid illusion it's
two things at once and which you see
depends on where you are
you see everything we perceive is made
of both local and global features
local features are abrupt spatial
changes like edges and fine details
global features are all we can see when
we're far away
general information about luminance
shape orientation and so on
if you overlay just the global features
of one image
on just the local features of another
you've got yourself
a hybrid illusion here the fine local
details of albert einstein
and a bicycle shares space with the
global general details of marilyn monroe
and a motorcycle from far away we can't
make out the fine local details
so we perceive only what the global ones
tell us